tengo cuatro puntos en coordenadas
cartesianas aquí y el primero es el
punto menos 10 ok que es vamos vamos de
hecho vamos a asignarle nuevos colores
para que vean cuáles son este es el
punto menos 10 también tengo el punto 0
1 aunque que lo vamos a hacer ahora con
este morado este es el punto 0 1 también
tengo el 1 2 el 12 que lo vamos a hacer
digamos con amarillo
12 ahora lo vamos a ubicar por amarillo
y el último que es el 21 vamos a
ubicarlo con el verde vamos a ubicarlo
con el verde y es este que se encuentra
aquí ok entonces ahora mi mío mi
objetivo es en este vídeo es hallar una
línea de igual a mx más ve que pase por
estos puntos y lo primero que puedes
decir es oye no habrá ni una línea que
haga eso y lo puedes ver inmediatamente
no sé por ejemplo puedes pensar en una
línea que pase por estos tres pero ya no
va a poder pasar por este cuarto verdad
entonces quizás podemos si no podemos
hallar una línea que pase por estos
cuatro puntos podríamos hacer una
ecuación y usar la técnica de mínimos
cuadrados para hallar una línea que para
que aunque no pase por todos ellos casi
pase por ellos ok entonces lo que vamos
a necesitar es es construir una una
ecuación digamos éste
digamos vamos a vamos a escribir fx
vamos a empezar escribiendo
y yo lo voy a escribir como una fx ok y
que ésta tiene que ser mx más ve esta es
la recta que estoy buscando sale
entonces sabemos por estos puntos que
por ejemplo efe efe de menos 1 déjenme
ponerlo alineado efe de menos 1 debe ser
igual a menos m ve correcto verdad
sustituyendo aquí y por otro lado debe
ser 0 verdad esta línea debe pasar por 0
en menos 1 también debe pasar también
debe pasar que efe en 0 pensando en este
punto debe ser igual a 0 por m que 0 + b
y eso debe ser igual a 1 muy bien
vámonos con el tercero más bien
efe de uno debe ser igual a m b m de
verdad y eso nos debe dar igual a 2 y
finalmente con el punto verde con el
punto verdes
efe
debe ser igual a 12 m + b y debe ser
igual a 1 muy bien entonces esto de aquí
esto que tenemos justamente aquí esto
esto ya no se está dando un sistema de
ecuaciones del cual podemos sacar una
toda la toda la información para usar la
técnica de mínimos cuadrados verdad
podía podemos construir una matriz a que
está dado por los coeficientes de las
incógnitas m&b entonces por ejemplo aquí
podríamos dar
va a ser una matriz grande este es menos
1 y 1 correspondiente a estos aquí va a
ser 0 y 1 verdad 1 y 1 y 2 y 1 y a esto
lo multiplicamos por el vector de
coordenadas m y b que son mis incógnitas
y debe ser igual a 0 12 10
2 y 1
muy bien ahí tenemos esta de aquí este
de aquí es lo que vamos a llamar a la
matriz a este de aquí es el vector x y
este de aquí es mi vector b entonces lo
que sí podemos saber es que como no hay
una línea que pase por todos los puntos
pues entonces no hay solución no hay
solución
no hay una solución para la ecuación x
igual a b no la va a ver no hay que
buscarle más ok pero lo que vamos a
intentar hacer es vamos a hallar vamos a
hallar un x estrella x estrella y como
ya lo hemos hecho que sea la solución
por mínimos cuadrados es decir que
satisfaga esta ecuación a transpuesta a
x estrella debe ser igual a a
transpuesta por nuestro vector b muy
bien entonces lo único que nos falta
hacer es multiplicar a transpuesta por a
y multiplicar a transpuesta por b y
resolver este sistema ok entonces sólo a
modo de repaso si suponemos que la línea
pasa por los cuatro puntos debe
satisfacer estas ecuaciones esto debe
ser cierto y es lo que nos da el sistema
que aunque no tiene solución podríamos
intentar usar la técnica de mínimos
cuadrados entonces vamos a bajarle un
poco para ver quién es a transpuesta por
a y sabemos que atrás
pues estos están estos renglones a hacer
los columnas y entonces tenemos menos 1
1 0 1
y multiplicamos por la matriz a que es
menos 10 1 y 2 y acá puros son 111
muy bien entonces esta multiplicación es
a transpuesta por a y entonces esta es
de 2 x 4 y este es de 4 por 2 me va a
quedar al final una matriz de 2 por 2
muy bien entonces vamos a hacer la
multiplicación de este renglón por esta
columna y es menos 1 x menos 1 es 10 por
0 0 1 por uno es 1 y con el 1 que
llevábamos es 2 y luego 2 x 2 es 4 y con
los dos que teníamos tengo 66 aquí vamos
con renglón y columna fíjense que como
multiplicamos por puros unos a este
menos 1 por 10 por 11 por 1 y 2 por 1
simplemente es sumar las entradas de
este renglón entonces menos 1 y 0 es
menos 1 y 1 nos da 0
y me queda finalmente 2
esto es 2 lo mismo va a ocurrir cuando
multiplique este renglón por esta
columna verdad porque son puros unos
multiplicando a esto entonces me queda
menos 10 es menos uno más uno es cero y
más dos me queda simplemente 2
2 y vamos a hacer
vamos a hacer el último que es este
renglón por esta columna y si se dan
cuenta es multiplicar 1 con 1 4 veces y
entonces eso es 4 verdad 1 2 3 4 muy
bien entonces esto es a transpuesta
ahora vamos a ver ahora quién es a
transpuesta por b multiplicamos a
transpuesta vamos a bajar un poco a
transpuesta que es nuevamente menos 1
012 y aquí 1 1 1 y 1 que multiplican que
multiplican al vector b que es este
vector de aquí
este vector de aquí 0 1
0 1 2 1
y eso me debe dar un vector y fíjense
esta es una matriz de 2 x 4 y este es de
4 x 1 entonces me debe dar un vector de
2 x 1 muy bien entonces vamos con este
renglón por esta columna y es menos uno
por cero es 0 0 por 10 1 por 2 2 y 2 por
1 es 2 si sumamos esos me dan 4 verdad
ahora vamos con 1 por 0 0 1 por 11 1 por
2 2 más el 1 que llevaba 3 y 1 por 11 3
que tenía 4 entonces esto es a
transpuesta por b así que finalmente lo
que nos resta es resolver el siguiente
sistema tenemos la matriz a transpuesta
qué es
224 que multiplica al vector x estrella
que es el que quiero encontrar y debe
ser igual a transpuesta por b que es 44
44 y bien bueno esto dejen escribirlo
porque aquí se estrella es el vector que
tiene m&b entonces déjenme ponerlo de la
con estrellitas en la siguiente forma x
estrella pues es el vector m estrella de
estrellas o esto recordemos es la
pendiente y la ordenada al origen
de nuestra línea verdad entonces esto
debe ser igual a 44 y bueno tengo mil y
un formas de resolver este sistema
podría tratar de pasarlo a su forma
escalonada en fin lo que yo voy a hacer
ahora para variar le un poquito es hacer
el sistema de ecuaciones entonces por
ejemplo esta primera representa 6 m
estrella más 2 ve estrellita debe ser
igual a 4 y el segundo renglón dice 2 m
estrella 2 m estrella más 4 ve estrella
4 ve estrella debe ser igual a 4 también
ok entonces fíjense que primero lo que
tengo aquí que resolver este sistema
entonces éste lo podemos multiplicar por
2 aquí multiplicar por 2 y me va a
quedar 12 m estrella más 4 de estrella
será igual a 8
y lo que puedo hacer ahora es este
renglón de aquí multiplicarlo por 1 -
entonces aquí será menos aquí va a ser
un menos verdad
un menos aquí y aquí va a ser un menos y
ahora vamos a sumar estos dos renglones
si sumamos estos dos renglones que me
quedan 12 menos 2 me da 10 m estrella 10
m estrella y aquí esto se cancela en
verdad aquí se cancelan y 8 menos 4 me
da 4 o bien en estrellas y pasamos el 10
dividiendo es 4 entre 10 o lo que es lo
mismo 2 sobre 5 2 quintos muy bien
entonces si en estrella vale esto lo
podemos sustituir en nuestra primera
ecuación y que me va a quedar
6 pone me estrella que es dos quintos
más dos de estrella que es lo que aún me
falta por conocer debe ser igual a
cuatro pero seis por dos quintos
simplemente son 12 quintos verdad más 2
de estrella debe ser igual a 4 entonces
ahora sí vamos a resolver vamos a pasar
esté restando y nos queda 2 b estrella
es 4 pero en quintos son 20 quintos
verdad menos doce quintos y esto pues 20
menos 12 son ocho quintos muy bien y si
ya tenemos esos ocho quintos y esos dos
estrellas de estrella es simplemente
este 2 pasarlo dividiendo y ocho quintos
entre dos son cuatro
entonces ya tenemos la solución que nos
da
el método de mínimos cuadrados porque ya
tenemos la m estrella y el be estrella
tenemos que x estrella x estrella es
igual primero a dos quintos dos quintos
y el otro son cuatro quintos cuatro
quintos pero recordemos que yo estaba
buscando la ecuación de una recta de la
forma igual a mx + b estaba buscando una
recta que pasara por estos cuatro puntos
como definitivamente no habrá una recta
que pase por esos cuatro puntos lo que
voy a hacer es que encontrar una recta
que minimiza el error minimiza el error
digamos dado por el método de mínimos
cuadrados verdad que minimice la
distancia entre el vector b y ax ok y
ese y esa solución está dada por este
vector este dos quintos de hecho vamos a
reescribir nuestra recta porque ya será
igual a nuestra m estrellita
dos quintos por equis más ve estrellita
que es cuatro quintos ok esta es nuestra
recta y vamos a tratar de graficar la
digamos 10 debe de pasar por cuatro
quintos más o menos es por aquí y debe
tener pendiente dos quintos es decir que
por cada cinco que avanza
digamos más o menos podríamos pensar que
que más o menos por cada que avanza una
mitad casi casi en un poquito más
entonces estamos pensando
vamos a pensar que se avanza una mitad
es decir se avanzó 2 en equis avanzó una
mitad de nieve pero una mitad quiere
decir un poquito
más o menos
ok y ahora el detalle el detalle
complicado es dibujar esta línea verdad
más o menos es así
más o menos es esta línea
más o menos esta es la línea que no se
encuentra el método de mínimos cuadrados
y es mi aproximación por mínimos
cuadrados que pasen por esos cuatro
puntos no encontrarás otra línea que
minimice el error de forma mejor al
menos no cuando me des el error como la
distancia del vector ve a la matriz a
por equis bueno espero que hayas
encontrado esto muy bonito